ouais merci
alors c'est quoi la suite c'est simple
on vous passe à un début d'extrait et
vous imaginez là puisqu'on parle de
coupe alors on s'aime c'est le thème de
votre pièce qui vont faire demain on
vous montre une image et vous dit ce qui
se passe après voici la première est le
premier extrait alors alors alors le
besoin de cerveaux d'accord mais alors
la suite c'est à la flamme de ce couple
va se raviver d'une manière particulière
et moi j'ai marqué sa marque sur ma
fiche demi va se radier si c'est bizarre
comme nous on sera vite mais l'homme va
être frappé par un par une gastro
fulgurante
c'est jean michel maire va débarquer en
plus grand bond est dégoûté c'est ça
marche
la flamme alors il faut de tout le monde
vote et saboter avec le gaz alors maxime
guy donc l'homme va être frappé par une
gastro je suis dit waouh scatophile un
je ne sais pas moi je suis le 9 av
aujourd'hui alors et l'abonné c'est là
bien sûr on vérifie en images regarder
c
moi j'ai eu ça comme accident avec ma
femme ça arrivait à michael jackson
aussi pour une pub pour le soda c'est
vrai c'est arrivé c'est vrai à brûler
sur ce jeu comme quoi il est concevable
merci alors oui vos passions un autre
extrait pardon bon allez on passe à un
autre extrait médias
[Musique]
alors c'est quoi la suite un invité va
tirer sur le tapis qui est au sol
mais la mariée va découvrir qu'elle l'a
oublié quelque chose qui ne m'était de
choses et c'est on va découvrir que la
mariée et et série la nonna écoute un
invité sa famille n'ait pas compris qu
trouver la bonne réponse et le troisième
accueillait brutalement voilà bien peu
tout vérifions en images
[Musique]
il est bien évidemment la réponse b bien
douce attention avoir l'oeil
c'est quoi la suite et bien voici la
séquence alors c'est quoi la suite jolie
l'action est ce que c'est la plus grande
est ce que ces affiches et moi les
propositions voilà un chien va venir
perturber ce moment romantique mais il
ne s'agit pas d'un couple
ou c'est emmanuel macron j'ai traversé
la rue pour retrouver un travail
allez-y d'abonder et intriguant c'est
assez connu on va vérifier en images
mais qui en chine
[Musique]
déjà mal
au mali on voulait tous les volets rend
jaloux vous mettez des dépôts la photo
et ça peut perturber le récepteur en
face il peut dire [ __ ] mais avec
quelqu'un et tout ça c'est bien à
condition que tu connaisses mais c'est
le même wagon que de mettre une assiette
devant et faire une photo sur un stade
pour faire croire qu'on est en couple ou
avec quelqu'un pour rendre jaloux quand
vous avez une vie trépidante vie de
merde j'avoue oui d'accord c'est
qu'ensuite on voit la ola larsen scène
de narnia les ménages c'est quoi la
suite voici les propositions alors la
mariée va faire une blague à son mari
careep ma télé mais servent avons
légèrement gaffes et où ces séries ligne
a doit annoncer que le gâteau manque de
croquant collectif c'est par ici en
images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est rasic cinq mariages se faisait
jamais arrivé ça d'abord gagné 4 appelez
moi j'ai moins quatre mariages mais
honnêtement plus dans un match souvent
c'est une pièce importante à piston fort
hills est si bas c'est cher c'est un
désastre
vous avez perdu mais n'ont jamais joué
vous n'êtes pas mariée vous non moi ça
m'est arrivé
non non de que la pièce montée tombe
donc à passer moi qu'il est démonté
parce que voilà tu as bien fait de le
dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
regardez cette vidéo c'est un garçon qui
est dans sa voiture un de sa copine
[Musique]
alors que va-t-il se passer à le
chauffeur va freiner brusquement mais
l'homme va avoir un petit creux ou c'est
dominique chapatte de turbo va pechos1
filles arrêtent de copier venant
justement vous donnez vous copier mais
non justement et dans les futurs
locataires alors regarde
[Musique]
et maintenant vous mangez tout le temps
plein de trucs que vous pourriez faire
ça c'est ça ouais c'est vrai ah oui bah
voila j avais pas pensé avec des
pistaches la bonne réponse et moi ceux
qui bossent un chef jf oui mais ça c'est
des images on est assez loin des médias
quand même alors j'ai un petit un petit
bonus pour vous c'est c'est une demande
en mariage on sait qu'ici on en a fait
quelques unes ont également gilles
d'ailleurs chez les loups attend
toujours la bague que vous la ramenez
souhaitait pas en bonne voire très bonne
voire très bonne avance ça avance bien
vous vois pas du tout auquel cas c'est
une situe de mariage
regardez c'est un petit bonus alors là
y'a pas à trouver ainsi qu'annoncé
[Musique]
kate
non la télé monsieur gilles c'est la
même que vous quand on line je me
reconnais dans ses yeux et n'avait pas
écouté c'est pas là